I
was advised to wording
that limitation came from the ME.
Sure there were years ago.
And when it's your own little interest in
me to use it
in an hour so lo and
behold we got a call from this young man that
was in a folder and he hit it up into
it with a bright. So all the time he was in there
so why isn't the girl told anybody
so we're by to visit them to placate
the couple they have here have a world away
morning with down to
the Catholic
Church in Kansas City.
Lasted about fifteen minutes and you didn't know long or what
was the whole lot of music. It
was in the is everything this is
where it would have been the player you know had she still been living there.
There's little doubt about merit is only lending a hand may be a
good thing and she's married young man twenty six
so he seems to really have a lamb and
this is going way his head
right with his family taking care of the
little children they have and the grandmother and the grandfather and and
everything we ever ever had was. You know he had to
give or I think you probably will have
some happiness. Sample himself
maybe. I have a little going back to the house
for a
really
really understand but I guess that's the way they do in
their way of doing things.
Anyway the wording was lovely and she had two
girls.
And two young the
Blazers came to blows.
She wasn't given away.
When they all marched down and there was a little back up
in the back of the
bell saying in saying that it
was in
the sale and one time that
it interested me that the bilingual never
once been touched. I guess is
the habit he put his ring in the ring. They
had community. And then
people in the church in his
view there were only about ten or eleven in there and all the rest of
the reason I was came because I
didn't really think that
would have brought me to
France where they had about a hundred twenty
five and the reception was that
it isn't
the
place. And
the labels that. Seven coal.
It started with them in the head
and then in the
head
and it was really
nice and then they bought everything is
separate and then when they got in
the thing. Nobody
nobody bringing
one and I mean the.
One.
With
me
and there was a nice couple that was
that he was married
and a couple
of
ladies. And she did
him and he
was then in Kansas City almost four years that he's been
able to buy in for.
You
didn't
say
Well children in
that tuna had twenty
three tuna
here
which is you know
but anyway she changed her brand.
And I was late and
then you
know where was the.
Well
anyway
waiting
and baby's
was
there
and this young man twenty eight
years of age and he's worked
with.
The community center.
I
don't know. This one. Well both
of them is where one was going to
pin ballots. And the news in the book. And
you haven't played
it and
then the way damn great
would do
you
think it was really it's out of the unique experience.
We're going back for
him to move waited until
the
first
couple
of.